[Musique]
vous n'avez aucun intérêt à ce que j'ai à
dire à moins que cela ne confirme ce que vous pensez que
vous savez déjà mon travail était simple sauver
le pays que j'aimais d'être détruit
est votre travail différent j'ai une piste
sur le grand ennemi de notre peuple  Adolf
Eichmann l'architecte de la
solution finale une piste s'est refroidie en 46 derniers
renseignements suggèrent un Osiris ce
type a convaincu les rabbins de charger les trains
eux-mêmes et non par la force si c'est lui
nous avons besoin d'un équipage d'élite je ne rejoins pas
vos têtes mais je  mettrait volontiers une
balle entre ses yeux, mais ce n'est
pas ce que nous faisons ici, c'est
strictement attraper un extrait Eichmann sera
jugé ici en Israël, pensez à ce que cela
signifie
finalement tenir publiquement le
contre-homme qui a organisé notre massacre
[Musique]
notre mémoire remonte  à travers l'
histoire enregistrée le livre de la mémoire est toujours un
œil ouvert et vous voici maintenant la main
qui tient la plume
[Musique]
si vous réussissez
bien la première fois dans notre histoire
nous jugerons à son exécution  r et nous
mettrons en garde tous ceux qui souhaiteraient suivre
son exemple,
vous pouvez échouer,
il échappe à la justice
peut-être pour toujours
[Musique]
Je vous en prie, ne vous trompez pas